this is the root that's absolutely  crucial leave that on there if you cut  that off the onion will start to bleed  and you'll start crying rapidly  slice going forward let the weight of  the knife do the work  three fingers  one in front two behind and this part of  the knuckle is going to guide the knife  fingers on top of the onion point the  knife towards the root and try to get  as close to the root as possible nice  long  stroke and then push the onion back  together  push the knife  halfway in to the onion slightly tilt  the knife down  one at the top  and then gripping the onion like a  tennis ball holding it together in place  with the weight of the blade to cut  through that onion to get to the base of  the root  again turn it round up and down motion  and that's what we're left there no  waste just the root there you've got a  really nice finely chopped onion